hello welcome back to a701
in this short video we'll be talking
about charge conjugation
um charge conjugation is a
transformation which switches
all particles the corresponding
anti-particles and vice versa
so you have a particle p
you apply charge conjugation on this
particle
and you receive it's anti-particle this
changes
all signs of internal quantum numbers
the charge the barium number the lepton
number strangeness
charmness and so on but it leaves the
mass
the energy the momentum and the speed
and untouched
on the electromagnetic and strong
interaction they obey charge symmetry
but the weak interaction violates such
charge symmetry
so charge conjugation it's a
multiplicative quantum number
like parity um you get identity
if you apply charged con conjugation
twice
you make an anti-particle and then you
apply this to the under particle
you get the particle back only particles
that their own anti-particles cannot
can be eigen states of this symmetry
you can see this here um you can when
you apply this
um you either get a positive or negative
sign
but this is only valid for particles
whose are their own anti-particles
as elementary particles that that only
leaves the photon
as composite particles you will see
later that there is a number of
mesons which can be their own
anti-particles
but we'll discuss this in the subsequent
lectures
by itself there's limited use to
the symmetry in order to learn things
there are some examples and we'll
discuss some in
in a recitation where you can learn
about possible decays
um for example in pions neutral pions
from applying this this symmetry without
uh knowing uh really what is the
underlying physics
um but in the next lecture we then talk
about
uh cp the you know the multiplication of
parity and charge conjugation
and some of the interesting effects
which occur from this